[Music]
do you have any tips and tricks for
laying out your schedule and calendar to
optimize your life and then from zane i
use my calendar to keep track of
upcoming meetings birthdays and
everything but i get anxiety when i see
upcoming events that i'm not looking
forward to
is there a way to reframe the way that
we look at undesirable but necessary
events
hmm
so that presupposes that
anything is necessary right so any of
any of these things are optional right
yeah there's a
louis ck joke about this so i'm not a
comedian and i don't pretend to be but
i'm gonna go ahead and butcher his joke
anyway but please do for the private
podcast
right yeah and and so since we're here
with just the patrons
we can but he talks about like what you
can get out of anything once all you
have to do is just end your life
right it's the ultimate excuse yeah
and
at first i'm like oh how you know
obviously he's joking but how cold is
that but then it's like but wait a
minute all of our lives are actually
going to end yeah
and is this what i want to do before the
end of my life
is this how i want to spend those hours
well it's just one hour yeah we tell
ourselves these stories so i can talk to
you about how i sort of
what did daryl say
laying tips and tricks for laying out
your calendar to optimize your life
that question stresses me out yeah
why the hell would i want to optimize my
life yeah i mean that's the problem is
we feel like we we have to constantly
optimize we have to make you know the
best use of every single second of every
single minute
um and that's just not it's not a
reasonable expectation yes like of
course we're gonna like do something and
and we might look back and say oh that
was a great use of my time where we
might look back and like oh i shouldn't
have done that but that's life i mean
it's not about
it's not about just living this
perfectly optimized life
it's about um
it's it's about actually doing the
opposite of that and learning from those
mistakes i think yes you will you will
learn you know sort of looking in the
rear view you'll certainly be able to
carry some some things forward
of oh that didn't work for me this did
work for me etc but when i'm looking at
my calendar today
i have very very few things on the
calendar and i do that intentionally
there's sort of three places from which
i work the first one is
my today list i don't have a to-do list
i have a today list
and at the bottom of that list there's a
someday list
and so i have a today list these are the
things that i need to complete today
these are the things that actually
matter that are important
these are the first thing on there is
the priority and then from there once
that is taken care of the next thing is
a priority now quite often what i
learned is that the thing i thought was
a priority actually isn't a product
because i don't have the time to do
everything in a day right and so
i don't schedule it unless i absolutely
have to schedule it on my calendar
and so
if i need to schedule it like a podcast
that we're recording right now that is
on the calendar i had a radio interview
this morning that was on the calendar i
have a doctor's appointment this
afternoon that's on my calendar but then
there are other things that don't
require a specific time i don't have to
be there at 2pm or p.m or whatever
those go on my today list
and then if i can't do it today it goes
on a sunday list here's the cool thing
about the sunday list i don't look at it
every day i don't even necessarily look
at it every week but if i go in there at
least once a month
i delete about half the things on the
someday list because the thing that was
so important to me today
ends up not even being a blip on the
radar a month from now a year from now
so those things that are so precious so
important so significant to you today
if you zoom out
a week from now a month from now a year
from now certainly a decade from now
there's a great chance that whatever is
so important to you today is not going
to be important a decade from now yeah i
think that relieves some
of the pressure yeah what's the third
thing oh i um i use my calendar i use my
to-do list my today list and i use my
inbox
and so yes
i do work from like an inbox zero sort
of thing but quite often what that means
is i get in there once a day and just
sort of triage certain things all
boomerang things to a different day
where i know i have time to work on them
i use uh there's a built-in feature now
even in gmail where you can
schedule i use an app called it's called
boomerang you don't have to use that
there's a built-in feature in gmail now
that you can just
schedule an email to come back to you
four days from now oh or a week from now
or tomorrow afternoon or whatever it
might be and that way i know i don't
really have time for this i need to
boomerang it now that can be a trap too
you got to be careful because just like
if you schedule something for your
future self oh i don't really want to do
this right now but um what did zane say
actually i use my calendar to keep track
of upcoming meetings birthdays and
everything but i get anxiety when i see
upcoming event that i'm not looking
forward to yeah well how do you get
those on there is because you said yes
to it a month ago oh yeah so
for zane the best uh response to this
question is start saying no more often
yes practice saying no now how do you do
that how do you compassionately say
no here's how you can passionately say
no instead of saying no you say yes
here's what i'm saying yes to and
because i'm saying yes to i'm playing
basketball with my son every night at 6
00 pm i can't say yes to your invitation
to be at the gala at 6 00 pm right and
so you they know what you're saying yes
too
and no one's going to be like oh you
can't play basketball with your son
tonight i need you to okay well then you
start to understand a whole lot about
that person i need you with a gala
hey i'm going to jump in for a second
guys because this is something that
keeps coming up and i don't know if
you're going to hit it or not but i
think it's important and that's memento
mori
remember that you will die
um you see that come up i know ryan
holiday talks about it a lot with the
daily stoic yes um you see it come up
from robert green's work a lot too i
think i write 48 laws of power but
uh
we have done such
a poor job in today's society we have
distanced ourselves
so far from death right we hide it away
used to be our society lived
with death right we saw people die in
front of us we slaughtered animals in
front of us we saw and it was a reality
right you realized wow
every day you saw
my time is not guaranteed yeah it's
never guaranteed
and sometimes uh it takes different
things for different people for me the
changing point was when my dad passed
away in 2013. you guys have heard the
story i don't know if the audience has
heard the story but just to recap really
quick
he died from complications from age at
orange he's exposed during vietnam and
korea
and as i was sitting with him in 2013
and he was passing away in the va
all he kept going over were the things
he wished he would have done
wow and all i could think about
as i'm talking with him and listening to
this is
we're not guaranteed any amount of time
if you want to do something you need to
do it now
don't be at the end with the regrets
yeah in our society we are actually
programmed to say i'm going to wait
until i'm 59 and a half or 65 or 68 or
whatever it is assuming we're going to
get there that's when i'll do the the
things that i really want to do right
well you know another way to look at it
too is like
when someone asks you to make a
commitment a time commitment
you can ask yourself like if i died you
know tomorrow
would i regret
not doing that thing yeah and that
i mean that that'll help you filter
through a lot of the yeses and no's yeah
because um
yeah someone asks you to i don't know to
a birthday party like for me yes i would
die like oh i wish i went to the
birthday party but josh would die and be
like why did i spend time at that
birthday party i wish i wouldn't have
gone to that birthday party
yeah
yes indeed
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast
and youtube channel 100
advertisement free